chaque jour 70 véhicules circulent entre
les 139 arrêts du réseau car jaune pour
un total de 90 bus quotidiennement un
entretien réalisé par de vie et il est
mécanicien
enfin quelques bus reste au dépôt pour
des entretiens et des entretiens
périodiques nous soit des remplacements
de plaquettes par rapport aux véhicules
que l'autre les gens en fin de compte ça
c'est juste pour des contrôles précis
les contrôles de sécurité pour que l'on
puisse partager la route avec tous les
âges et la route le réseau car j'en sais
ce qui relie beaucoup de rayonner
entrons enfin cours pour pouvoir avoir
un moyen de déplacement pour pouvoir
aller au travail pour moi aussi ben
c'est l'opportunité et la chance que
j'ai eue de pouvoir découvrir un métier
qui est le mécano la mécanique poids
lourds à plus de 250000 euros l'unité
ces gros bijoux de technologie nécessite
une attention particulière à savoir
faire transmis par le chef mécanicien
le secret il faut folie aime ce métier
pholien il faut pas faut pas lire la
presse alliali tout ça il faut il faut
lire cl im palais ne peut pas continuer
de se battre c'est la mécanique pas là
il ya beaucoup de pièces lourd c'est pas
les gestes par des pièces divers il ya
des pièces lourdes tout ça mais il faut
maintenant quand même assez le gabarit
pour lui ça va le gabarit des gabarits
ça va mais même des fois même là avec la
gabarre il faut je viens en aide tu
joues à vieillir ah bah oui ah bah oui
tu y as com - thomas samson bon goût
pour découvrir la grâce en erreur j'ai
appris plein de choses enfin quant aux
nouveaux de colo toujours du jour en
rêvant d'en sortir
maintenant on va c'est grâce à mes gars
à à l'équipe veut que seront variables
comprennent que ce service permet
d'assurer une sécurité de chaque instant
aux clients des cars jaunes une
vigilance au quotidien alimentée par la
passion du métier
on a un très bon réseau fun changement
changement de réseau depuis deux ans
donc on a beaucoup de véhicules neufs
c'est quand même assez confortable et
c'est ça qu'on a pu enfin qu'on de
découvrir un autre métier et aussi
d'être au service du client même si
l'union et ses pas
des véhicules performants et fiables
sillonnent le réseau car jeunes et ça
c'est un peu grâce à ces hommes de
l'ombre